bonjour françois le belge à merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
un juge qui demande donc une enquête du
parlement sur trois ministres du
gouvernement libanais qu'est ce qu'on
peut attendre de cette enquête
ben tout ça le première chose beaux
jours qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre des
jalles enquête et très secrète donc on
sait pas où est ce qu'on doit donc
paysages et la première fois on va à ce
niveau de responsabilité
mais les ministres qui sont interrogés
là ne sont pas ceux qui nous ont fait en
fait qui nous ont amenés à c'est la
situation actuelle
donc ce n'est pas ce ministre là qui
conviendrait de devoir c'est plutôt ceux
qui suivent ensuite c'est leurs
prédécesseurs plus tôt c'est une
procédure donc rare vous venez de le
dire au liban mais quelles sont les
chances justement qu'elles aboutissent
je ne vous entends pas oui vous venez de
dire que c'était une procédure qui est
rare au pays du cèdre
quelles sont les chances qu'elles
aboutissent cette enquête le précédent
c'était dans les années 90 on a eu un
scandale sur les produits hydrocarbures
sur les dérivés d'hydrocarbures et à ce
moment là on a eu des ministres qui ont
des anciens ministres qui ont été mis en
examen et qui ont été jugés depuis on
n'avait pas en fait de recours de
justice la haute cour de justice
ici elle est nommée par le par une
partie nommée par le parlement une autre
partie par des juges et jusqu'à l'année
dernière en fait le parlement n'avait
pas nommé de des deux députés comme si
jean dans cette haute cour de justice
donc on avait un capacité à juger des
ministres
ce qui est intéressant aujourd'hui c'est
justement le fait qu'on puisse voir des
responsables est ce que cela va ouvrir
l'autre porte ensuite notamment aux
affaires de corruption
ou de détournement de fonds publics il a
haute cour de justice a été mise en
place justement parce qu'il y avait eu
l'année dernière des accusations selon
lesquelles des détournements plus de 11
milliards de dollars avaient été
détournés durant les entre 2005 et 2009
alors que l'ancien premier ministre
fouad saniora été au goût était chef de
gouvernement
et c'était une sorte de réponse un bras
de fer
comment est ce que l perçu cette demande
d' enquête par la population vous dites
ça pourra qu'être ouvrir des portes pour
d'autres justement d'autres enquêtes
ça permettrait d'ouvrir la boîte de
pandore c'est ça ton problème de
connexion décidément françois el bacha
oui je disais comment est ce que cette
demande d'enquêté perçue par la
population
un problème technique visiblement
problèmes de liaison avec françois el
bacha merci en tous les cas d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes économiste et fondateur du
site d'information libnanews